I have nothing against a company
offering me to freeze my sperm eggs or
whatever I just would like to see the
context in principle why not I don't buy
this totally paranoiac attitude you know
that that this is just another means of
control manipulation and so on and so on
my god we are entering a new era if we
want it or not we're having children and
so on will be totally denaturalized
the problem is not shall we do it or not
the problem is under what conditions who
will control it and so on and so on to
be even more precise I am NOT a fan of
Facebook and Apple and so on and so on I
agree with Julian Assange who compared
Google in a wonderful metaphor recently
to private just privatized NSA you know
it I agree with all this I'm not saying
that the solution is not simply to
remain stuck then we are acting like all
European social democracy to remain
stuck in the golden era of welfare state
or here human right we cannot avoid it
we have to accept that this is happening
and will be happening more and more
the way out is not simply to say don't
do it just to prohibit is nothing else
if we don't do it others will be doing
it like crazy so you know we have to
confront the problem but no basically
basically I'm I know of the great
anxieties problems new forms of control
but it's also new forms of freedom this
is why I always emphasized that internet
and all these new digital stuff it's a
very ambiguous phenomenon but it's the
field of struggle new forms of
enslavement but at the same time new
incredible forms of freedoms we have to
accept the fight with no nostalgia for
old
allegedly more authentic community
or whatever I'm not afraid of this